so we're doing a cup test with you yeah
this lightweight is going to punch you
in the cup is that all right i told
aaron it was a light weight
i didn't tell him it was a heavy weight
that's not a flight wait what are you
guys talking about
you lied to me i meant heavyweight but
lightweight came out
i'm a ufc fan so i heard francis
singhaner was going to be there and i
was like i want to do it please please
and then later i found out in fact i
didn't want to do it
i just googled the hardest punch ever
recorded
his punch is the equivalent of being hit
by a foreign escort at top speed why you
don't need to read that now
[Laughter]
you waited until the fourth theatrical
release to become a real star
[Music]
the world waited for what felt like
forever
then
we waited longer
but this february
we promise it's gonna be the gnarliest
[ __ ]
ever the wait is over
[Music]
hello i'm johnny knoxville welcome to
jackie
if you're
if they trust us to go to the bathroom
they're less intelligent than i thought
to know
if you're gonna be dumb you gotta be
tough you're still blowing people up as
if life's not hard enough this guy's one
badass dude
[Music]
oh man i'm on jackass is it texas rat
snake venomous
[Applause]
francis hits harder than any heavyweight
in mma i told aaron it was a lightweight
that's not wait what are you talking
about
[Music]
we're in this together pops what's the
worst that could happen
[Music]
you said it wasn't gonna feel like
anything
[Music]
i just need you to like sit with my
grandpa just make sure he doesn't smoke
a bunch of nasa scientists right now can
i get a cold thing
[Music]
will you make him an actual coffee
stephanie i made you another one
it's gotta be over dude i think we're
all the way finished we're through
stick a fork in it
[Music]
you